campaigners caught up in a so-called
leasehold trap taking mass legal action
for the first time
hundreds of leasehold homeowners in the
northwest have served notice to forcibly
by their freeholds from big investors at
least hold only gives you exclusive
ownership of the rights to occupy the
property for the length of the lease and
Sky's Ali Fortescue has been speaking to
one owner who feels she has been ripped
off I want around the property that I'm
paying a mortgage for it doesn't sit
right with me and it gives me many
sleepless nights actually somebody else
actually owns my property soon after
giving birth her son nurse Katie
Kendrick bought her leasehold home she
believed she'd be able to quickly buy
the freehold but without her knowing it
it was sold to a big investment company
who've now quoted her three times the
price to buy it outright I absolutely
feel like I was misled at the point of
sale
had I known then what I know now there's
no way that I would have entered into
such a vulnerable complex system that
I'm now trapped in if it was their
intention to sell my freehold on they
should have been upfront that at the
point of sale so I absolutely believe
that I was misled and Mis sold this
property lease holds are essentially
long-term tenancies they're
controversial and almost unique to
England and Wales at a time of valuable
ground rent incomes this murky corner of
the property market means professional
land owners can reap the rewards while
the lease holder pays the bills
many of them have high ownerís ground
rents and also terms of the lease that
where the lease holders have to pay for
permission to change anything in their
house we've seen people who've been
asked to pay five and a half thousand
pounds for permission to build a
conservatory in their own gardens or two
hundred pounds per room to change a
carpet what makes it difficult for lease
holders as individuals is that they have
to pay the freeholder costs for any
legal battle for their home but now for
the first time hundreds including Katy
have joined together to take on big
investors and forcibly buy their homes
but some are calling this a David and
Goliath battle lease holds a lucrative
business for investors and people like
Katie are struggling to fight for the
right to own their home alley food skews
Sky News